Okay.
Today I want to do,
I want to do two things.
I want to talk,
uh,
about the centralization of the French state and the question why Paris.
And that's kind of fun to talk about the role of Paris in the centralization and
the particular role of Paris in French economic,
political,
social,
and cultural life.
And then I,
in the last,
you know,
20 minutes,
I'll talk about why,
uh,
this sort of strange man,
the,
the former miracle baby,
as he was called after his birth,
uh,
the Coulter Shamba did not become king of France,
Henry the fifth,
and why France ended up,
uh,
a republic.
And how,
and that has something to do with the centralization of the French state.
Now,
anyone who has ever spent any time in France at all was ever waited in line.
And in a prefecture and in a pre via or a genre or a or a or Paris,
God forbid,
a roommate for hours,
uh,
will realize that the role of Paris and the role of the centralization of the
French state,
uh,
is unique,
in,
at least in western European history.
Um,
and over the long run.
And it still is,
despite all of the mutual halls plans of for decentralization and the creation
of regional councils,
uh,
basically,
France remains the most centralized state in,
in western Europe.
Um,
and the role of Paris in French life,
uh,
does not have an equivalent in other European countries.
Now,
let me think about that.
Let's think out loud about that other statement.
Uh,
think of other countries,
uh,
in,
Spain.
Obviously,
uh,
Madrid modality is the capitol,
but,
but a,
a Barcelona is terribly,
terribly important,
uh,
and was always a much more economically,
important,
uh,
city than the kind of command economy that was Madrid.
Or if you think of Berlin,
I mean,
you think of Germany,
a unified Germany or in the,
in the federal public before German unification,
uh,
Berlin,
it was terribly important.
Uh,
it is now again,
I the capital,
uh,
but Berlin is balanced off by Munich and by Frankfurt in some important ways.
Or if you take a little country like Scotland,
uh,
Edinburgh and Glasgow are two major cities.
Or if you take a England,
for example,
uh,
people,
I came to care,
uh,
in very major ways,
what people in Manchester Thought,
uh,
because Manchester becomes a,
the capital essentially of the north and the economic,
uh,
center of production.
If you take Russia,
Moscow was always the,
you know,
the religious,
uh,
core,
the a ridiculous,
the second just hated Moscow.
It represented all those values that he thought was,
was what was,
uh,
were Russian.
Uh,
but Saint Petersburg Leningrad became,
uh,
the Cap Petrograd Leningrad became a major,
major,
uh,
um,
city.
Uh,
and,
uh,
because of the residents of the czar,
that's where it was.
Or,
um,
if you take a almost anywhere else,
the officer or Gary and empire,
uh,
before it broke up,
Vienna was now this oversized capital that,
that,
uh,
in a very,
very small country,
but it was balanced off by,
by Budapest in Rome,
in Italy,
obviously,
uh,
Milan and turn were terribly important cities in Rome with just this,
a sleepy ecclesiastical,
uh,
capitol full of,
of,
uh,
of tourists and,
and clergy.
Um,
but Francis unique,
uh,
Paris,
the role of Paris and French life,
uh,
is unique.
And,
uh,
that has been accentuated,
over,
uh,
over the centuries,
particular last century and a half by some of the things that I want to,
uh,
talk about.
Uh,
in,
in 1947 about,
there was a book published called Paris and the French desert,
uh,
that looked at this sort of a unusual,
unusual thing that where else,
but in France would then 97% of the population,
uh,
be considered provincials,
in a very derogatory,
very pejorative sense.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Paris,
would be the place that all of the Ras,
gene acts of France,
uh,
would try to go because of the economic,
political,
social,
and cultural domination of,
of the capitol.
I will ask you to neck,
uh,
was that,
who's before this course?
Uh,
but was,
uh,
the,
the central figure,
one of them in Balzac's novel,
old go,
he'll go.
He'll,
and he's a sort of a somewhat poor noble from the show haunt,
uh,
in,
the west of France who's going to hit the big time and wants to sleep with all
the right ladies and,
and,
uh,
become,
become wealthy without doing any work.
Uh,
and he became sort of a symbol for this,
uh,
aggressive,
provincial in this case,
uh,
sort of poor noble who has to get a to Paris,
to make,
uh,
and make the big time because the big time,
could only be,
uh,
be,
be there.
Um,
now,
I mean,
it almost any domain you can think of,
I'm one exception and this is not the time for me to talk about it though I
would love to do that,
uh,
is a gastronomy because although,
you know,
the,
uh,
Leona is considered though they almost not the capital of any region.
It was a second most important city in France and still is,
even though it's slightly smaller now than in my say.
Um,
if you just count the,
the city Leona became the capital of French,
like astronomy and not Paris,
but that's almost,
uh,
the exception.
Um,
and,
and one of the reasons why the role of the domination of the dominance of Paris
is so great is precisely because of the centralization of the French state.
You know,
in my memory,
uh,
as a,
you know,
as a young guy,
uh,
you know,
hanging out and drinking a cheap wine,
uh,
in a,
in Paris.
Uh,
you know,
when I was doing my,
my thesis,
um,
you could only hear on the news,
uh,
people with [inaudible] accents a giving the news only,
and then they,
before the newest,
they had this little thing they call sult.
[inaudible]
as you are now,
where if you lived in a van,
you know,
uh,
there would be,
you know,
you would have a 15 minute,
uh,
a program talking about local events.
And you might have somebody who had an overnight accent,
or if you live in my,
say a or a niece,
or you might have somebody with a southern accent giving,
uh,
you know,
the news about local schools and,
and,
and having pictures of young women presenting flowers to some,
uh,
you know,
corrupt politician.
Uh,
and it,
it would be like that.
But basically the news was always given by people with a northern accent,
either a Illawarra acts I lower valley accent and they're very proud of,
they think they speak the best French but oppression,
accident.
But that's all that's all changed.
But the reality of the situation that front,
that Paris is overly dominant,
um,
has not changed at all.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
and Balzac I mean to go to back to above Zach,
he,
he put it the way [inaudible] view of the provinces.
And this is still a still the case.
Uh,
he described provincials as being dominated by routine and monotony in their
small towns that they're all the same.
He wrote,
which is obviously not a [inaudible],
not the case.
He says,
provincials are like moles brewing it burrowing and their little plots or frogs
at the bottom of their puddles engaged in sorted trivial rivalries move by petty
jealousies,
avarice and material interests.
Since they do not sync about the things that are serious,
uh,
they get excited by tiny things.
Um,
now you used to have,
there's a very famous cover of the New Yorker in which you had,
uh,
a,
you know,
a map of the United States I've seen from New York and where you had New York
and then you had this sort of large,
you know,
ditch that are finally,
and then Los Angeles was a half a football throw away.
Uh,
and everything in the middle was this sort of,
uh,
desert basically.
Um,
and,
and certainly the way that,
that,
that provincial people,
including myself and we're legally residents and France,
and we live in all dash and I'm proud of it,
uh,
view per regions.
Uh,
it's often,
uh,
with that same kind of contempt that the parishioners look at us.
Uh,
and then,
I mean,
for example,
in France and one,
if this ever disappears,
I'm going to be one and a happy guy.
Uh,
you know,
the license place,
the last numbers of the license plate tells you where people are from.
So if you have,
if you have a s a s,
you know,
a 61 year from the all,
and if you have a 62 year from the [inaudible] la,
or if you have a 63 or for them,
we did dome.
And you can amuse yourself as you're driving along saying,
well,
that guy from,
uh,
you know,
from,
from a chateau rue is off to visit his cousin in,
in,
uh,
this and song.
And I mean,
that's the way I get by driving a long rides.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
Eh,
during the vacation season in July and August when all of us down here are
inundated with tourists,
uh,
you know,
when people see that was 70 fives,
which is the license plate for Paris or I,
this is not on the test.
Uh,
uh,
but it,
or if they see,
you know,
they know it's Paris and it's Paris region.
And they know that there'll be certain expectations,
often condescending expectations that will be in the way that is.
And,
and,
and people from the Atlanta and put Azn present themselves,
visa vi,
you know,
we pour a struggling frogs in our little ponds.
Now that is,
uh,
you know,
that has changed,
uh,
for,
for sure.
Uh,
but,
but the centralization of the French government and the domination of Paris over
the life of the nation,
uh,
has,
is a very difficult to,
uh,
to,
to change over a long period of time.
Now.
Um,
I guess one of the key kind of indicators of what's going on,
I mean,
in terms of economics,
uh,
you know,
the domination did dominance of,
of the Paris region in terms of the economy is that Leon,
uh,
which was always Francis,
second city,
uh,
first and gastronomy.
As I said earlier,
uh,
the,
the Big Bank of Leon,
uh,
the Grady ne,
that is the legal bank,
uh,
in the 1860s moves its headquarters to Paris,
not in Lille as if it's sort of given up.
And people,
for example,
who follow the Leo Opera.
Oh,
I said,
well,
our opera is fine.
Uh,
but it's nothing,
of course like Paris where all the resources are poured into Paris.
How did it get this way?
I mean,
just thinking over the long,
long run,
how did France end up so,
uh,
so centralized,
I mean,
all states,
uh,
you know,
centralized,
uh,
became larger and centralized their ability to extract resources from their
population.
If you take Europe and 1500,
year,
1500,
there were about 1500 territorial states,
and they range from big consolidated monarchies like Spain and England and
France to,
uh,
to,
bishoprics,
uh,
such as trigger,
in Germany that were hardly bigger than the gardens of the Archbishop's,
uh,
who ran them.
But over a long period of time,
state making is one of the central processes in European history.
Uh,
the creation of a more powerful monarchal monarchical states,
uh,
and eventually of national states with a variety of political outcomes of the
unification of Italy.
To the extent Italy has ever been unified,
uh,
the unification of Germany,
you know,
uh,
in 1871 in Italy,
in the 18,
a 50s and 60s.
But in the case of France,
uh,
if you go to the 16th century,
if you go to these,
these chateau around the Luau,
and you see all of these,
these beautiful furniture that's been been made by,
uh,
by skilled artisans,
you know,
when you always see,
as you see this big case with handles on it.
And they were,
you know,
that's where the king's documents and the,
and the,
and the minister of,
of whether the Gal,
the soda,
what would the chief financial officer and justice officer,
uh,
where,
you know,
all their papers were because the monarchy really didn't have a capital.
The monarchy was wherever the king was.
And it's in the 16th century that Paris becomes the capitol.
Paris is not in the middle of France as you can clearly see.
Uh,
but you're,
you know,
you're not going to have a,
a capital in Mono Saul,
uh,
or something like that.
Um,
and so you ha you have,
uh,
you know,
you have the,
the,
the kings there and the whole process of absolutism,
which you don't have to know about,
but you know,
it's in the,
it's in the 17th century that European rulers,
uh,
expand their power visa vie their enemies,
you know,
land grabbing.
That's how France ends up with El Sauce.
Uh,
n,
uh,
as I said before,
increasing their ability to extract resources,
uh,
that is to take money from,
from a very ordinary people.
And,
and so,
uh,
Louis the 14th,
you know,
who liked to call himself the son,
God,
uh,
you know,
a modest megalomaniac,
uh,
he sends out officials into the,
into the provinces to enforce his will.
And these dudes are called a intendance,
but that doesn't matter if you don't have to remember that.
But they are out there and they'd go through a process of negotiation with local
elites,
with nobles,
and with the law courts.
But in the end,
the only thing that matters is that,
that this increases the power of the state.
That is during the period of absolute monarchy that armies become enormous.
And if you're,
you know,
if you travel around France,
you'll see all the fortifications of volleyball,
uh,
you know,
who is a military genius.
Uh,
we'll ball and fortresses Pepin y'all and,
and,
uh,
along the pier and he's there and up and lead,
and up along here,
uh,
you'll see these fabulous fortresses and the fortresses had to be maintained by
people who are going to test the guns,
the canons that make sure they work and to be there all the time.
And that's,
you have this enormous increase in standing armies now.
And then the cure comes to French revolution.
And what does the French Revolution want to do?
Well,
it wants to rationalize the administration of France and wants to do other
things too,
but that's not this course.
And so,
um,
uh,
instead of having,
you know,
where you,
before you had something like a hundred tolls,
you had to pay on the La River.
If you're transporting some goods.
Uh,
they eliminate all those tolls.
They try to create uniform weights and measures and that'll take a hundred years
before that really works.
But what they do is they increase the power of,
of the center of the government and in order,
because they're their arch enemies are the nobles who are hightailing it toward
Germany and toward England and everywhere else and trying to launch wars against
the revolution.
What they say is when we will undercut the authority of the church and the
nobles in the provinces by creating what they call departments,
departments,
they popped them all.
And so they create the departments that become part of this administrative
system so that every department,
and this sounds boring,
but it's actually interesting.
Um,
every day pop them all in France,
most of them are named after rivers and some after mountains or proximity to the
sea.
Uh,
we'll have the same officials and that these strings that reach out into now 95
departments in France,
including Corsica,
all lead to,
uh,
to Paris.
And that where someone once said that gall was divided into three parts.
Now what happens is people living in any region in France,
the three parts that they see are the Ministry of Justice,
the Ministry of war,
and the Ministry of the Interior.
So you have these day pop them all.
And these are created in 1790 and they still exist.
The only big change came in 1960 when they consolidate the ones around Paris.
Um,
but because of,
of the growth of,
of the,
of the Paris region as you can see there.
So I,
if you take number one,
but we don't have to go to the mall and I sure we won't.
If you take number one of the Al Ain,
it's named after a river.
Or if you take number two,
the end ais and d is named after a river.
And how many hundreds of thousands of people died along there,
uh,
in world war one or you take number three,
the same thing.
Yay.
Uh,
they're named after rivers and they don't all,
they're not all the same size.
The biggest physically is Doyle don't join,
uh,
which has probably grown because there's so many British lived there.
Uh,
uh,
something like 8,000 full time residents.
Uh,
I'm pointing toward the shrunk.
That doesn't do any good,
but anyway,
cause going to get close.
Sometimes I,
I can't see.
Uh,
and then the smallest is the Pyrenees Oriental,
uh,
which is French w Rusi on which is French Catalonia.
That doesn't matter.
But the point is that the revolution in order to defeat its enemies further
centralize this estate.
And then along comes the little corporal.
It's the little general,
the little a megalomaniac,
uh,
Napoleon and one.
And He of course,
push pushes centralization even further where he liked to brag.
It's one of his famous lines you'll find in textbooks,
but that he could look at his watch and see what all the kids in the least say
that he created the high schools we're studying at any one time.
And He makes state centralization,
uh,
even more important.
Um,
and then in the third,
I mean,
the second empire,
1852,
uh,
18,
70,
uh,
his,
his nephew who,
who some wag one's called the hat without the head.
Uh,
Napoleon,
the third,
uh,
what he does is his,
he uses centralization is that tool of the state to consolidate his own power
and that of the empire.
And that is to undercut the residual influence of,
of the nobility.
If you wanted something,
and this is still true in France today,
it doesn't do any good to go to the local notable like you did in the 18th
century.
Say,
Hey,
you know,
it'd be mature,
a little guide.
That would be great if,
you know,
if we,
if we had a school,
uh,
it doesn't do any good at all.
And he realizes that.
And so the patronage of the empires to he can provide railroads,
he can provide money for things and that further central Isis,
the state.
And so you've got these processes in the 19th century economic processes that
are,
that you find all over Europe that can consolidate the power of the French
state.
Centralized in Paris.
Railroads is a good example.
Uh,
and sometimes I'll throw out examples.
You're not responsible for them.
It's just kind of hopefully interesting for you to think about.
If you think of,
I have two towns down here,
believe a,
B,
r,
I,
v,
e who famous for his rugby and two t,
t,U ,
l,
e.
O,
which is a capital I mentioned the first day,
cause that's where lots of people were hung.
They were the same size in the 1850s but breve gets the railroad and not to the
railroad from Paris.
And so that centralization as a,
you know,
it also,
there are mountains there.
It's easier to build in breve but the state can make or break regions with their
economic patronage.
And one of the reasons why France ends up with a,
with a republic and not a monarchy is because these prefects who represent the
republic can go into conservative regions to say,
hey,
we didn't really like the way the elections came out last time.
You're miserable council on lot of monarchists there.
You would like a bridge across your river,
wouldn't you?
And that was the case in our village,
cause there wasn't a bridge across the river.
And there's a little boat would take people across this often swirling dangerous
river.
Uh,
and you want to be your bridge.
Well,
let's see how the elections go next time the state can provide these services.
And you know,
the evolution of banking in the 19th century further consolidates power.
There are certain economic takeoff in the 1850s and sixties in Paris because the
state banks are in Paris,
the state financial institutions are in Paris,
and they can make or break a,
you know,
investment in all of these places.
Now the railroad,
even in our day,
uh,
maybe not your day,
but well,
yeah,
still in your day.
Uh,
I mean,
I was on the Tj the third day it opened,
which was,
it opened on September 28th,
1981.
And I was there on September 30th taking of the trip to Leone though it only
went fast.
Uh,
when it got to a really got to a certain point here now,
but the,
the railroads,
if you look at the map of the railroads and France and anytime you want,
including now all roads lead,
all tracks lead to Paris.
So,
for example,
now if you want to go from,
say you're in [inaudible] and you want to go to Boldo,
you're going to be broke.
The reason if you,
unless you can take about eight hours to do it,
because the way you're going to do it is that you're,
you're going to take a train that goes one hour and 58 minutes to Paris and then
you're going to take another train that zips down here in about four hours to
Boldo,
but you're paying by kilometer.
So it's going to be terribly expensive.
Uh,
when I was commuting between the motion Paris,
um,
uh,
you know,
you,
that was still a long trip then.
There was no Tj,
uh,
it was about four hours.
Uh,
and when I once took the train over to,
uh,
to,
to Poitier over to plot,
ta took three hours to get,
because if you go across the lines,
it's not good.
Now,
how to train another,
I mean,
obvious reasons how trains reinforce the predominance of Paris.
take my business.
Uh,
you know,
the teaching a profession is that the domination of Paris is such that,
that you have this phenomenon in,
in France,
which they still call up,
that they call it turbo puff.
And a trouble train was a fast train before the TGV.
The first ones went to Normandy.
The carry the wealthy parishioners to Deauville,
uh,
in a turbo profe is somebody who lives in Paris and whose dream is to teach at
Paris,
particularly at Paris,
one French universities are named very politically Paris,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
all the way through 14,
which is a real hole or 13 is probably the worst.
Uh,
but the turbo prof will be somebody who is assigned to a mass and who takes the
train there every day or to tool,
but to Leone also,
since this is only two hours,
this is 440 kilometers,
you know,
two hours.
You can be on the damn train to New York City.
And you'd be lucky if you get 80 miles in two hours or an hour and 50 minutes.
So you've got people who live in Leone who teach in Paris or friends of mine
that teach in Lille and live in Paris.
Or I teach in wrong,
uh,
frequently who live in Paris and teach in a wall.
Now,
um,
this is bad because what it does is there sucks local university life out.
And it means that there's this phenomenon of the Turbo prof has been accentuated
by the fast train,
the fast train,
by the way,
keep referring to it is called the [inaudible],
the Atlanta.
They're going to Levy Tessa cause it,
you know,
so hula,
it goes fast.
So I mean,
the 19th century accentuates all of this.
Uh,
and uh,
the,
the result is it's still by 1947 when,
when gravity,
he wrote this book called Paris and the French desert.
If you look at an encyclopedia,
uh,
the definition of,
of,
of provincial as somebody who's provincial was still provincial,
someone who is Gauche.
And that's not politics,
who's kind of a Bumpkin,
kind of a [inaudible],
you know,
kind of a day late and a dollar short who lacks Dick's distinction.
I'm reading this right out of the Larousse dictionary.
Um,
uh,
for example,
to have a,
to give the impression of being provincial with,
you know,
like you've just arrived at the train from Brittany and Garma Parnoss and you're
just so totally out of what,
you can hardly find the place to buy crap and the,
and that's all you want to do a,
and you're sort of the sort of clueless.
Um,
and so the departments along with the railroads,
uh,
and along with better roads also,
and the banking network,
um,
uh,
increases,
the centralization of,
uh,
of the French state.
And I mean,
I can remember,
you know,
this is about 20 years ago,
but there was big demonstrations from people in,
um,
uh,
in,
in Brittany because of there's always these boats crashing ashore and oil slicks
all over the Breton and coast or people that produce artichokes.
The price of artichokes,
you know,
cause of they may volunteer mean the prices are so low,
they're,
that they're always rushing down to the prefecture and dumping artichokes in the
prefecture and protesting.
And I can't remember.
There's one amazing,
uh,
a photo,
from the plastic that come called,
which is a big place in Paris,
had big square where you've got these Breton mayors who are wearing their
sashes,
the tricolor sashes,
red,
white and blue.
And the police are using the crs,
which are the military police did a little less vicious than they used to be.
But,
uh,
I was in a demonstration against Sarcozi and mid,
mid May and the police were the crs with their sort of carte blanche.
Now we're,
we're,
uh,
we're fairly aggressive,
but anyway,
these police were wrestling to the ground,
these mayors who are protesting using their tricolor sashes to,
you know,
threatening to strangle them with their own,
uh,
sashes of their authority.
I mean,
only in France would this be possible.
Uh,
and so every government that comes to part of,
they say,
well,
we're going to do something about this.
You know,
the golf said,
let the,
you know,
he didn't really say that was mild,
but let the,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of flowers bloom.
But the gall,
I mean to go,
who will talk about later mean to goal said,
how in the hell can you run up a state in which they're 440 different kinds of
cheese?
I mean there are a lot more than that.
And he believed that it was insidious in order to,
to have these sort of regional cultures.
I mean it was,
I'll give you an example.
It was illegal.
It is still illegal in France to name a baby,
a name that is not officially approved.
Absolutely.
There was a,
uh,
or even to adopt one.
There's a famous case in the 1970s or eighties there was a family called tone.
You own a Tonio as a cigarette butt.
And when they tried to adopt a baby,
that would be called a,
let's say as you won't Phillipe tone y'all.
They said,
oh no,
that baby would be damaged by having such a last name.
You don't have the right to adopt this baby.
And there were cases where Breton's tried to name their children Breton names
and the French state said,
ah,
because it wasn't a officially French.
Well,
the goal has been been dead for a very long time and there has been progress.
But what has not changed is still the power in Paris,
in these ministries,
uh,
to dictate the life of a,
of schools have almost everything else and a lot of the strikes that you see in
high schools and in,
I'm going to get to my lecture,
but you see in high schools and,
and,
and even in middle schools,
I have to do with,
with,
you know,
the state something they saying,
well,
we're going to take away 200 teachers in your department or we're going to,
we're going to maintain a curriculum that doesn't seem to make any sense.
I mean,
my son,
when he was in the,
in,
um,
uh,
seg on,
which is the first year of French high school,
I mean,
they were out blocking traffic until some angry driver rover rolled over.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the foot of a protestor.
And then everybody kind of went off on a pizza.
But,
but,
but these were these,
these were reactions against what the state,
what we're trying to do.
Or in the 1980s when there were huge demonstrations by people by favoring the
Catholic Church as an institution,
uh,
visa vi education.
I,
it was the same thing with the rack thing against the kind of,
uh,
dictate dictates or Dick Todd coming down from Paris.
And when Gumby ta,
whom you can read about am I mentioned the other day when he said clericalism
there's the enemy.
And then you had this sort of campaign against the church,
uh,
particularly the teaching aspect of the church.
That's fascinating.
Uh,
which I'll talk about later.
So France ends up like that.
Uh,
many people,
uh,
saw themselves as I'd made these tray.
That is people who are administered,
uh,
who are governed but in the sense of having people passing papers back and forth
and having to sign every damn thing you could ever imagine.
It's just,
it's just an unbelievable,
uh,
before the ever thought of themselves as being a citizens.
And certainly there is no other country in the post communist world in which so
many people worked for the state.
Now,
having said that,
let me just say as an addendum,
and this is my opinion,
you could ignore it,
that uh,
things work in France.
And it used to be that 20 or 30 years ago he said nothing in France works and
everything works in the u s and now it's just the opposite.
Uh,
totally the opposite.
And if you're going to be sick and unless you're wealthy or you're better off
being sick in,
in France and you are here because,
so the system really works and there are abuses,
but the social security system,
which encompasses more than just what we mean by social security,
the Cecu,
which involves healthcare is one of those things that really works,
is annoying as the whole structure and the taxes and all of that.
And of course the challenge.
So this is the latter part of the course is what do you do with this and Europe,
Europe,
as you know,
which is going to erase these license plates and are going to take away part of
what it means to be,
to live in France.
And that's why I would have voted against the constitution.
I encourage people to vote against the constitution.
And I know almost nobody except professors in Paris and Leone who were for that
constitution that was defeated a year ago,
May 29th.
So there,
anyway,
now how did this all happen that,
uh,
given the fact in February of,
of,
uh,
of 1870,
you had a monarchal,
a monarchist dominated assembly elected,
uh,
in which rural regions particularly,
particularly,
but not necessarily just Brittany and,
and,
and Norman d and o van.
You know,
these are big still Catholic regions as we'll see later that they wanted the
restoration of the monarchy.
Why does that not happen?
How does this country end up being a republic?
The third republic,
which has been castigated or been denounced because it seemed to fumble along,
but it was the longest republic.
Uh,
and it lasts from pending on when you start it.
And you can read about that,
whether you're the Utah you started in 1875 or 1877,
or when there really was a republic Republican early eighties.
It lasts until May,
uh,
June,
1940.
So how did all that happen?
Now here we move into,
uh,
a history that is the kind of old style history.
Uh,
it's the story of decisions taken by a individual.
People.
Um,
there was a pretender to the throne and this man was,
uh,
got off his life,
got off to an interesting start.
Uh,
he was dubbed the Miracle Baby for reasons that I will explain.
The Quantas Sean Bar was,
uh,
a borbon.
Uh,
he was part of the royal family of,
of that was a Louis the 14th,
and Louie the 16th.
And,
uh,
in 1820,
his,
he,
his father was assassinated by a liberal,
a man called Louisville.
And he's at the opera.
He gets kind of bored and he walks out,
they leave the opera and this Guy Lavelle comes up and he stabs,
puts a knife right through him.
And it was not just a,
you know,
a random act.
He wanted to extinguish this royal line and the Boardmans had been restored in
18,
15,
1830.
Again,
this is her old style history.
So France goes into great morning,
uh,
the church bells ring very,
very slowly all over the place because,
uh,
there is the heir to the French throne is dead and there's a huge campaign
against the liberals because of that.
And then Lo and behold,
it turns out that his widow to whom he confessed various infidelities before
expiring was pregnant.
Indeed,
he was the father.
They didn't run DNA tests or anything,
but he was the father and as France held his breath,
uh,
cause they wanted a boy,
this miracle baby was born and no phone do meet hockey.
And the unfortunate thing is that he was sort of a sad sack and pull the Tepe.
It's tough being the pretender to the throne.
The would be,
uh,
Henry the fifth,
and your name recognition is such that in royalist towns and the east and the
west of France,
I like know that somebody would in the middle of night would scribbled graffiti
long live Henry the fifth,
and that people would get together in,
in Church on January 21st,
the date that Louis the 16th was executed and they would pray for the
restoration of the Boardman Bourbon throne.
But there's also another family of,
of,
uh,
of pretenders.
And that is the orderliness,
the [inaudible] niece.
But orderliness,
I just wrote there in English.
And these people,
this is kind of boring,
but these people were in government between,
uh,
1830 and um,
in 1848.
And King Louie Felipe,
who was chased for chase from the throne in February of 1848,
uh,
was seen as progressive.
He was seen as the bourgeois monarch,
but he was perfectly noble.
He'd gone to Kentucky and drunk lots of Werblin.
Once,
uh,
he carried an umbrella,
that sort of middleclass symbol of protection.
Uh,
and he has chased,
uh,
from the throne in,
in 18,
uh,
48,
but he'd helped modernize the economy.
Uh,
he,
uh,
and he did not restore the church too.
It's old.
It's old power.
And the orderliness were extremely clever.
We're Shambu was,
was,
was thick as a brick,
um,
and spent most of his time telling antisemitic jokes and playing cards with his
cronies and an Austrian capital,
uh,
and,
and the Austrian capital and mountains near,
uh,
near Vienna.
Or maybe it was near Salzburg,
I guess it was near Salzburg.
The orderliness had a bunch of sons of Louis Felipe,
who are,
who are pretty clever,
uh,
one.
And by the way,
just about 10 years ago,
the oil and his family suffered,
uh,
it kind of an embarrassing reversal when one of the Orleans,
sort of the third in line,
if there was ever an orderliness,
rest of a restoration with throne was arrested for burglary as being an
accessory for burglary in the period oriental.
But anyway,
so when,
when France collapsed after the war and went with the cotton,
when the commune comes along,
it seems to royalist that is the people who wanted to restoration of the
monarchy that their ship had come in.
So what's going to happen now?
It's easy to make fun of,
of,
of Shamba who was a pullover,
a TP,
a sad sack in many ways.
Um,
but the history of royalism is not,
it goes beyond that.
Uh,
and there was a strong royalist movement as I've already suggested.
And it wasn't just people looking backwards.
Indeed,
he said in his various pronouncements written for him by someone else,
uh,
that he didn't want to be a king of the old regime.
He did not want to turn the clock back to 1788.
Uh,
and that you could bind a modernity with monarchy,
but there was never any doubt that if he was restored to the throne that he
would rule.
And you have to imagine him after the commune.
Ah Ha.
After the slaughter and the buildings are still burning,
uh,
or at least smoldering that he comes to Paris and he'd never rather,
like Louis Napoleon had hardly ever been in Paris before me.
He really hadn't,
I don't think ever.
So he gets a carriage,
he rents a carriage and he goes around as a tourist and he goes to Notre dom and
he goes to San Chappelle and he goes to pay homage at the,
at what they thought were the remains of,
of,
uh,
his,
departed ancestors.
And he had bone fragments of what they thought,
or at least,
uh,
ashes of Marie Antoinette that he,
had with him in his room all the time.
And so,
you know,
but it's not that he has his entourage,
he has his posse,
he has his entourage,
but there also are the strong,
uh,
traditions of popular royalism of ordinary people and peasants who believe
fervently in the monarchy.
Uh,
you found them in very odd places.
There's a strong tradition in Neem,
one of my favorite places of popular royalism.
Uh,
and also of course in Brittany.
I keep giving Brett tone examples.
I'll pick other ones.
Uh,
so,
you know,
th th and also because of the closest association of the monarchy and
particularly the legitimacy there called legitimate the bourbons with the
church,
uh,
you know,
you've got fertile ground in areas that were still practicing a religion.
And we'll talk more about that.
Uh,
another time I,
he makes clear that he is going to restore the church too.
It's,
uh,
two,
it's what he considered rightful place of privilege in France.
And possibly,
I mean,
he could benefit from the wave of religious revival that occurs in France in the
end,
the night in the 1870s.
Now,
every time there's a big time political disaster from the point of view of the
Catholic church in France,
it's followed by a period of,
of religious revival after the French revolution.
And Napoleon and Napoleon makes peace with the church.
Uh,
there is,
uh,
all of a sudden the revival of people forming religious confraternities of
people paying to rebuild churches that had been vandalized during the revolution
where they're melting down a church bells to use and as cannon and things like
that.
Uh,
the,
the famous,
a beautiful,
fabulous,
a monastery of a church monastery,
Church of,
of Cuny,
uh,
is,
of near Mack Hall right here.
I hadn't been destroyed and they tried it.
They restore a couple of the remaining,
uh,
towers.
Uh,
and as chateau beyond said,
the writer,
you know,
I don't know what we must believe that women must believe in something and they
get to,
he gets on his knees and prays.
The same thing happens in the 1870s.
There's a revival of,
of that old time religion and it's helped by,
you know,
various miracles and that kind of thing.
But,
which I'll talk about in the lecture on religion,
which is kind of fun.
Uh,
you know,
[inaudible] fun to do.
Um,
if for example,
when you go to any town or any village in France,
you will see what they call a mission crosses.
You'll see these crosses that our stone crosses.
The first ones were put up during the,
the counter reformation or the Catholic reformation in the 17th century,
uh,
to try to win back areas that had become Protestant.
That is around [inaudible].
Uh,
you find some that are put up,
not surprisingly,
after 18,
15,
and the others are in the 1860s or the 1870s,
and then never again.
And these are big crosses that are put out usually outside the villages,
uh,
and sometimes times that the,
the crosses were destroyed during the revolutions.
There's a huge interest destroyed and the revolution of 1830,
but most of these crosses,
you can read them.
This is an iconography of belief and you can see the dates because they'll put
the date like 1868,
there's about 10 of them in our village.
Some of them,
there's this little,
you know,
stumps left,
but,
but it's kind of fun to walk around and look at them.
But here are these proliferate wildly.
And so the,
there'll be missions am I remember when I went to Jesuit high school in
Portland,
Oregon,
we had to have these retreats or revivals and the priest would,
these missionaries would come in and,
and,
and for three days Sundaram chew and then people would,
you know,
go off and go to confession and,
and,
uh,
I didn't have much to confess.
I often wish I had had,
but,
uh,
in those days,
in high school.
But anyway,
there we go.
You'd go and do these things.
Uh,
uh,
and it would be a sort of public spectacle,
a spectacular.
And so Henry the fourth Henry the fifth could,
could,
uh,
you know,
could capitalize on that because there were lots of people that would be very
happy to see him come back because of their,
uh,
belief.
But it's hard if you're 47 years,
uh,
your job is,
is a pretender to the throne.
Um,
it's,
it's difficult.
He had a hard time getting around.
He'd,
he'd had a very royal accident.
He'd broken his leg,
falling off a horse,
um,
and he had a hit,
a terrible limp.
And also because they just sat around and played cards all the time and ate and
drank.
He became quite a large,
uh,
large man.
And occasionally he would get up.
I'm going to look at the relics of,
uh,
of,
um,
uh,
Marie Antoinette.
And then he'd go back and play cards for big stakes.
He was a big time gambler.
And because he wasn't very good card player,
his,
uh,
his posse to confer a,
for a fairly sizable amounts of money,
but he viewed hereditary monarchy quote as the unique port of salvation.
That's a very religious image,
uh,
that could,
could save a France.
And he talked about strong authority,
uh,
underplaying judicious liberty,
for example.
And the key to his strengths besides the church is the nobles are the nobles
now,
um,
having a noble title,
then Jude do a hell of a lot of good,
uh,
after,
um,
after the French revolution.
Uh,
and it's easy to give this sort of a,
this sort of stereotype of nobles as being just letting their nails grow very
long and,
and,
uh,
drinking nice wines and chasing each other's Mr [inaudible] and wives around the
gardens.
Uh,
you know,
val cy or anywhere else.
Uh,
uh,
in fact,
many,
uh,
nobles became chairman of the boards of various companies and,
it's,
uh,
there's still had these atavism is these throwbacks to the old regime where,
you know,
it was sad near to lose that.
If the noble announced after mass that it'd be good to have a little firewood
that he could look out from the Ponderosa and see peasants,
obedient,
obedient peasants carrying large stacks of wood up to the big house.
And maybe they get a little something on Easter,
uh,
from,
from the big guy.
But basically the state was winning the battle against the nobles and you could
still be the,
the co count of anywhere or the Duke of anywhere.
And you can't mobilize goodies to give to local people except on a very local
scale.
And the state,
the state is winning out now.
Gone Beta,
who was a smart guy who dies very young,
he said,
uh,
that,
France became a republic because,
uh,
most of the people wanted Republican.
They didn't want a monarchy and that's all there was to it.
And the elections in the early,
uh,
1880s would certainly,
make this,
uh,
um,
clear.
Now,
there was even a group of nobles who believed that they could be elected,
did,
if you had an election,
that people would,
would actually vote to restore the monarchy.
These were kind of the popular royalists of places like,
like Neem by the way,
I should write these things down.
Neem.
See the older gene,
there would've been an s there and that's why you got this little shadow up
there.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
but,
but that wasn't going to happen because the most people in France ultimately did
not want a monarchy.
But what about a old,
uh,
Sean Bar when he was,
you know,
when,
when disaster came,
uh,
he was not ready.
A key issued poorly constructed manifestos,
uh,
in order to,
to espouse quotes the freedom of the church as the prime condition of the peace
of spirit and order in the world,
uh,
and the,
to protect the,
the pope was the glory,
the honor of our country.
And the most thing that castable because of its,
if its glory a among nations,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
but there was a big problem that for all of his failings,
human failings,
and they were indeed many and his intellectual limitations were,
which were a daunting,
uh,
he was a man of faith,
and,
uh,
loyal t to his principles,
for better or for worse in this context.
And in 1789,
when the bourbons were when Louis,
uh,
when the revolution came and then executed old Louis the 16th,
the white flag of the bourbons plain white flag of the blurb borbons sometimes
we're the flirted lease on it and all that was replaced by the red,
white and blue flag,
the three colored flag,
the Tree Kununurra,
uh,
which,
was a combination of adding the color white for the Boardmans in 1789 to the red
and blue that was there were the colors of,
uh,
um,
of,
of Paris,
of the city of Paris.
And in the end,
he refused to compromise.
When his advisers say,
look,
we can pull this off if you agree to accept it.
The three colored flag of revolution of the French revolution,
which had killed his family members.
And he refused to do that.
And they tried to make a deal with the orderliness and the orderliness produced
children one after another.
But,
uh,
Sean boy had no children.
And so upon his death,
who is going to follow him if he's going to be king?
And so they propose a deal.
Why don't you be king until you Croak?
They didn't put it quite like that.
Uh,
and then the organist will take over with the red,
white and blue flag.
And he said to his credit,
no,
without my principles,
I am just as he put it rather than delicately and cruelly about himself.
A fat man with a big limp.
And he went back to his castle,
antisemitic jokes and card playing buddies.
And so France lurched into a period called the,
the,
the moral order,
the Republic of the moral order.
You can read the details of this,
which are not fascinating,
but what we got,
we'll get through this and move on to more interesting things.
In 1875,
there's an amendment to the constitution that essentially Trent and voted by one
vote,
approved by one vote by the assembly that essentially trans forms,
uh,
France into a republic in 1877,
a general called Mac Mall,
uh,
who had fought in the 1870,
71 war.
You may think that that's not a very French name.
There's a strong Irish influence around Boldo.
In fact,
one of the Great Bordeaux wines,
it's called Lash bodge lash as in Lynch,
which is an Irish name,
but Mac,
my home was,
was a French,
uh,
and that he is a general and becomes president of,
of the state and he tries in 1877 on the 16th of May to overthrow the government
and basically a question of responsibility to whom it's not interesting.
He fails to do that.
Uh,
and France in the early,
uh,
1880s,
you have this sort of rooting of the republic and a rooting in the Republic of
the republic because most people in France wanted one.
It seemed to be the regime,
the divided France least.
What gumby talk called the Nouvelle Kush or the new social strata,
the new social strata,
the middle classes,
the petty bourgeois,
uh,
workers.
Obviously I didn't want a monarchy,
uh,
but in,
in,
in many areas of France,
particularly in the south,
lots of peasants did it,
did want to,
uh,
did want to republic and France,
becomes,
uh,
becomes a republic.
And this republic is,
is strongly identified with Paris.
And if,
because of the fear of Caesar Ism the fear of another Napoleon or another
Robespierre before that or another Napoleon the third,
they create a executive authority that's extremely weak.
Power is in the Chamber of the deputy of Deputies and the assembly and the,
the president is a convener.
He tries to get people to do the right things and it's a political club.
They all,
twice each other.
They,
even if they hate each other's politics,
I mean,
they call each other by the,
the informal name.
Uh,
and even though it's decentralized,
it does not mean that the state is not strong and that the state will not be
making decisions that will affect the lives of ordinary people.
And the most controversial of those decisions will also only be in 1905.
Uh,
if,
if you exclude going to war and getting all these billions of people killed,
uh,
was the separation of church and state.
And that is the work of a,
of a strongly centralized,
uh,
government centered in Paris,
as I said,
over and over again,
uh,
but imposing its will for better or for worse on the provinces.
And in doing so,
following train tracks,
uh,
following the roads,
following these centralized sort of vines that going out from Paris into the
provinces as a way of exerting its will,
its influence and its patronage.
And then conclusion,
the state becomes the,
becomes the new ways that,
that patronage,
uh,
economic,
financial,
cultural,
uh,
political is dispensed.
It replaces,
uh,
it replaces the nobility,
the local nobles.
It replaces the church,
and it replaces the monarchy that most people in France did not want.
Next time,
let's talk about identity and let's talk about one of my favorite topics.
The role of the schools in towns and in villages.
Sia.